en france maintenant les violences ont
duré sept heures toute la nuit jusqu'au
petit matin à redon en ille et vilaine
les forces de l'ordre sont intervenues
pour empêcher l'organisation d'un
teknival on regarde ces images de notre
journaliste jacques beaudry le bilan des
affrontements selon la préfecture cinq
gendarmes blessés dont deux évacués à
l'hôpital et un jeune de 22 ans qui a
perdu une main
une enquête est ouverte par le parquet
de rennes sur place il y avait environ
1500 personnes venues faire à la fête et
rendre hommage aussi à steve majaka
nietzsche aux deux ans presque jour pour
jour après sa mort en marge de la fête
de la musique à nantes
emmanuel berthier le préfet d'ille et
vilaine a donné plus de détails sur les
événements regarder des heurts d'une
extrême violence ont duré une grande
partie de la nuit les affrontements ont
duré sept heures les gendarmes ont reçu
des cocktails molotov des boules de
pétanque des morceaux de parpaings dans
ce contexte un jeune homme de 22 ans a
perdu une main
une enquête a été diligentée par le
parquet de rennes
nous évaluons la situation avec le
ministère de l'intérieur pour mettre un
terme à ce rassemblement interdit qui
s'est traduit par des violences forte
totalement inexcusables
je demande très clairement aux
participants de quitter les lieux et
pour alex et poulain éditorialistes il
ya un vrai problème de dialogue entre
les forces de l'ordre et la jeunesse
écoutez le évidemment ça pose la
question de la stratégie et de la
doctrine du maintien de l'ordre
la gendarmerie de vettel utiliser ces
moyens là pour disperser les fêtards qui
n'avaient pas d'autorisation ou bien est
ce qu'il y avait un moyen simplement de
dialoguer d'éviter le pire sachant que
la jeunesse est en cage depuis plus de
deux cent quarante deux jours couvre-feu
loi d'exception confinement elle est
bien sage cette jeunesse et elle a
besoin évidemment de faire la fête
sachant que le couvre-feu va tomber
bientôt que l'été arrive mais comment on
en arrive à avoir six heures
d'affrontement pour une fête une fête
voilà où on en est comment aussi c'est
possible de se dire que lorsque steve
maniaque à nice au avait disparu à
nantes
il a fallu des jours avant qu'on parle
de cette disparition
et puis des rapport de l'igpn qui
faisait état en fait finalement de d'une
disparition ne certainement pas due à
charge dangereuse de la police sur ses
quais de nantes donc il ya un vrai
problème je pense de dialogue entre les
forces de l'ordre et les jeunes les
organisateurs d'événements alors certes
la critique vient du fait que c'est un
événement non autorisé mais ça n'empêche
pas le dialogue ça n'empêche pas
d'éviter ce genre d'affrontement ce
genre de violence